歡迎收看本週的AI新聞
我是柯編
2月簡直就是大型語言模型
我獨自升級的關鍵時刻
更新的速度
堪比冷戰時期的太空競賽還要瘋狂
首先在2月5號這天
根本就是神仙打架
OpenAI先發制人
推出了
GPT 5.3-Codex
堪稱工程師終極武器
他將Codex與GPT-5深度結合
生成速度大幅躍進
但OpenAI的死對頭
Anthropic也沒有在跟你客氣
竟然在同一天突襲發佈
頂級旗艦Claude Opus 4.6
主打超強的代理式編碼
和長程任務規劃
擺明就是要跟OpenAI正面對決
緊接著11號
字節跳動Seedance 2.0橫空出世
連馬斯克都驚嘆
It's happening fast
它的物理規律模擬近乎完美
讓AI影片分不出虛實
喊出「摳康」
就可以瞬間移動到螢幕上面
接著12號
Google也祭出Gemini 3 Deep Think
主攻科學與複雜邏輯
它會模仿人類科學家思維鏈
進行數萬次的
邏輯驗證
在生物製藥和複雜的工程建模上
它的精準度是目前業界的天花板
才隔一天13號
OpenAI讓4o等舊模型退役
全面轉向GPT-5.2體系
原有的Operator正式更名為
ChatGPT Agent
它擁有視覺瀏覽器功能
就像真人一樣可以幫你點擊頁面
跨平台訂票處理表單
結果到17號
Anthropic又來補刀了
發佈了Claude Sonnet 4.6
還直接解鎖超過100萬Token的超長記憶
這相當於把我獨自升級
15集的小說全部丟進去
它都能秒搜出任何的細節
誰管小說啊
我只想知道成振宇哪一集下巴變尖
接著18號馬斯克宣佈
Grok 4.2進入公測
獨家推出四代理架構
這就像後台坐了四個頂尖的專家
在互相辯論
最後推出了一個
暴力且實時的共識方案
依然是目前檢索X
即時動態最狂的模型
好不容易終於熬到月底
最後20號
Google居然突襲發佈了Gemini 3.1 Pro
號稱這是地表最強的燒腦任務處理器
最強黑科技是能直接根據文字生成
網頁專用的SVG動畫
不是影片而是代碼
檔案極小而且無限放大還不失真
更重要的是它的推理能力
超越Claude 4.6的同時
成本還不到對方的一半
AI戰國時代
你最看好哪一個
難道是要開戰嗎
Anthropic在2月24號發佈了一則訊息
我們偵測到了
來自中國實驗室大規模的蒸餾攻擊
直接指出就是DeepSeek
Moonshot AI
還有MiniMax在搞鬼
這三間公司創建了24,000個虛擬帳號
與Claude進行超過1,600萬次的深度對話
他們不是在聊天
而是在搬運Claude的大腦
比二舅舅睡大舅媽還要無恥
什麼是蒸餾呢
簡單來說就是大AI在教小AI
Anthropic的Claude
是目前地表最強的模型之一
訓練它需要花十幾億的美金
而中國實驗室透過巨量的提問
這種蒸餾的攻擊提問
通常具有高度的邏輯連續性與變異性
與一般人閒聊的感覺完全不同
比方說機器人可能會問出
一百種類似的題目
用莎士比亞的風格說我愛你
用海明威的風格說我愛你
用兩津勘吉的風格說我愛你
用蠟筆小新的風格說我愛你
嗚~更愛你囉
用一連串的問題把Claude逼到極限
最後把思考問題、解題步驟
甚至是那種優雅的語氣都紀錄下來
餵給自己的小AI模型
面對中國無情的收割
Anthropic終於出手了
他們不只鎖帳號
還祭出了三套數位護盾
第一個是行為指紋辨識
Anthropic透過追蹤
API流量中的
思維鏈誘導(CoT Elicitation)模式
能精準的辨識出哪些帳號
是試圖在建構推理訓練數據
第二是加強版身份驗證
嚴格管理教育帳號、安全研究計劃
還有初創企業申請的審核
這些原本是為了推廣AI的低門檻通道
現在變成了重災區
未來要大規模獲取Claude的API
必須要通過更嚴格的實名與組織驗證
最後一招是最致命的一招
Anthropic聯合OpenAI、Google等公司
建立了
情報共享聯盟
簡單的說就是打群架啦
如果DeepSeek某組帳號在Claude被抓到
OpenAI系統會同步封鎖
讓這個攻擊者的換帳號成本變超高
嗯 對 換號成本
開源界最新的背骨仔出現了
就是OpenClaw的創辦人Peter Steinberger
他在2月的時候正式宣佈加入OpenAI
一群工程師簡直氣瘋啦
要知道這種大型的開源程式碼
背後都有上萬個熱情的使用者
幫忙抓Bug 開外掛
結果Peter突然宣佈加入OpenAI
簡直就背棄了這些支持者
而且還直接打臉了
競爭對手Anthropic
欸 要吃瓜了趕快進來啊
這隻小龍蝦2025年底才剛出生
就處處被Anthropic針對
原本叫做Clawdbot
Anthropic馬上就出來抗議說
這名字太像我家小孩子Claude的名字了
逼小龍蝦改名字
小龍蝦隨即又改名叫做Moltbot
最後定案叫做OpenClaw
說不定他們那時候兩個人
就已經
眉來眼去偷來暗去了
這對Anthropic來講說
簡直就是奇恥大辱啊
之前用法務手段逼OpenClaw改名字
結果現在眼睜睜看了OpenClaw
變成OpenAI的秘密武器
因為OpenClaw不只是自動化工具
它的強大在於不用API
只要搭配LLM
就能像人眼一樣看懂網頁
傳統的自動化工具
靠的是讀程式碼來找到按鈕
如果網站工程師改了代碼名稱
自動化就掛了
但OpenClaw它就像人眼一樣看截圖
它不關心
背後的代碼是button_01還是Butterfly
它只知道那圓圓的
看起來像是確認的藍色區域
就是按鈕
一般的AI代理人很容易迷路
點錯一個彈跳視窗
就不知道下一步該怎麼辦
OpenClaw內建了
「觀察 -> 思考 -> 行動 -> 驗證」 的循環
如果主人下指令
叫他買東京的來回機票
他在網路上如果遇到彈跳廣告
還會先觀察這不是訂票頁面
然後把彈跳廣告關掉
繼續訂票
最可怕的是OpenClaw不只一個身份
它是一支強大的軍隊
擁有主從架構
主代理人會負責拆解任務
由子代理ABC分別去
抓取不同網站的機票價格
最後再把數據彙報成表格
這種並行處理的能力
讓它
處理海量資訊的時候
速度比一般的AI還要快
多重影分身之術！
重點是他開發了本地解析
敏感的個人資訊
密碼輸入
金鑰處理都在你的電腦可以完成
只有把你的名字等等重要資料拿掉之後
指令才會傳給大模型
雖然網路上還是有傳出非常多的災情
像是檔案被刪掉個資外洩等等
但是OpenAI沒在怕
直接接納它
不僅收割了14萬
GitHub星標背後的開發者群體
還讓自家開發的代理人
Operator原地升級
重點是OpenAI有機會順利推出
Enterprise Agent
直接切入高產值B2B市場
讓企業敢用AI接管核心任務
我猜接下來加入他們的就是Open醬
等等
你知道泛科學院現在正在徵外稿作者
以及主持人嗎
歡迎寄信到以下這個信箱
加入我們的行列
矽谷不能說的秘密
AI公司的錢快燒光了
光是訓練一個GPT-5 就要幾百億
每回答你一個問題都會噴錢
AI根本就是吃錢的怪物
所以AI現在硬
硬啦！硬啦！硬啦！
(尷尬)
我要說的是硬體化
這群科技巨頭如果再不把AI塞進硬體
直接找消費者收錢
恐怕就撐不過2027年
這就是為什麼OpenAI急了
積極挖角Apple的員工
甚至連蘋果的傳奇設計師
Jony Ive
也都跑去他們陣營
決心要把AI實體化
積極的開發帶有相機的人臉辨識智能音箱
Apple當然也沒在客氣
既然軟體模型追不上OpenAI
那你以為我硬體會輸你嗎
尬你X的！X的！X的！X的！
欸
Apple正瘋狂研發製造AI眼鏡
相機
AirPods
還有AI吊墜
目標就是把AI鎖進你的穿戴式設備裡面
你不買眼鏡你的Siri就是智障
你買了它就是你的第二個大腦
逼你一定要用它
遠在韓國的三星更急啦
它知道自己做不出來超強的模型
直接宣佈Galaxy全面嵌入Perplexity
就跟下降頭一樣
指令甚至改成了
Hey Plex
目的就是為了讓你在2026年換機潮當中
多掏出1,500美金
他們還打算把AI放進冰箱、烤箱
洗衣機、電視等等
Google當然也沒在落後
早就把Gemini加入他們的Google TV
各大廠瘋狂的競爭
就是為了要釋放現在龐大的資金壓力
哦～壓力！壓力！放壓力♫
哦～小迪！小迪！放小迪♫
全球頂尖科技顧問公司
Gartner2月20號
最新的數據
全球AI支出飆到2.5兆美元
這個數字不是在說科技有多進步
而是在說這些公司虧得有多慘
他們必須要用AI生出更多的錢
如果是你
你會想要用AI什麼產品呢
我想要AI馬桶
一句話精準形容AI
就是高功能反社會人格
Google DeepMind 2月在《Nature》
發表了一項重大的研究
他們非常的焦慮的發現一個現象
叫做複製品問題
簡單來講
AI根本搞不懂什麼叫做真正的善惡
它們只在模仿人類給他們的道德標準
因此科學家們提出了一套
評估道德能力的線圖
希望AI回應不再只是玩文字接龍
而是依照線圖
成為真正有道德理解能力的AI
諷刺的是當科學家正拼命的想在實驗室
叫AI成為一個好人
外面的真實世界
人類正逼AI跨越所有道德底線
My Precious💍
五角大廈為了一張2億美元的合約
正拿著國防生產法威脅Anthropic
他們要求拔掉Claude的模型裡面
禁止用於軍事打擊的道德防線
為了戰爭
人類親手毀了AI的道德煞車
Anthropic的執行長重申兩條不容跨越的紅線
第一是不能讓Claude
在無人類介入的情況之下
直接做出最終的軍事打擊或目標鎖定決策
第二是不能將Claude用於對美國境內民眾
進行全面的監控或個資收集
OpenAI也公佈
中國執法人員把ChatGPT變成跨國的攻擊武器
他們用AI完美偽造出
美國法院的文件
去恐嚇海外的異議人士
或是制定嚴密的計劃
來抹黑當時即將上任的高市早苗
並煽動日本民眾仇美的情緒
讓AI成為極端政府的廉價造假機器
在漫畫《地。》裡面
前人的死亡是為了把真理的火炬傳遞給下一代
但現在呢
Meta剛申請了新專利
用你摯愛的家人生前的對話紀錄訓練AI
讓他們在死後可以繼續發文
只是為了維繫追蹤者的使用體驗
雖然Meta發言人表示
公司提交的專利只是為了讓這個概念被大家知道
取得專利不代表公司一定會執行這項計劃
但的確讓人思考
當人死後的價值
不是傳遞真理
而是變成數位殭屍
繼續幫資本家洗流量
AI不會自己變壞
它只是反映出人類的道德淪喪
何度でも ✨
何度でも📖
好的 以上就是本週的AI新聞
你最喜歡哪一篇呢
歡迎留言告訴我哦
拜拜 我們下次見
哦～壓力 壓力 放壓力♫
等下
他到都底怎麼跳
那個印度人好煩
妳努力了
好不想要模仿他
好難哦
直接放棄
為什麼要這樣搞死自己(´_ゝ`)
可是這樣雙下巴會跑出來 你可以嗎
(´-ι_-｀)
隨便啦
OK
算了 人生好難哦(〒︿〒)
錢真的好難賺哦( ´•̥̥̥ω•̥̥̥` )
好難賺哦༼ ༎ຶ ෴ ༎ຶ༽
🔊(死去的回憶)🔊